Yeah so neodymium is one my favourite f elements
to work with. When
you use it in compounds and you dissolve it,
often you get colourful blue
solutions from it. Sometimes they are green
as well, but often I have
found that if concentration of the solution
makes a really big difference
to the colour of these solutions so you may
have a compound which
appears to be red but actually as you dilute
it down eventually it ends up
being blue, which is really pretty and sometimes
if you cannula it from
one flask to another and you can see through
the cannula you can see it
change colour as it goes through the cannula
and then drops into the
next solution again.
So neodymium is one of the rare earths and
it has a number of quite
important applications. One of my favourite
is in lasers, it’s used for
example in this laser pointer and if you point
the laser it makes this
rather nice bright green colour.
A little known use of neodymium is that the
size and strength of volcanic
eruptions can actually be judged from the
composition of neodymium
isotopes which are present.
The first laser pointers were red. They didn’t
use neodymium, and the
green ones have become really quite fashionable
among lecturers. So
the way this works is that inside here there
is a small crystal, of so-called
neodymium YAG, is the sum of the neodymium
atoms that are isolated in
the glass that contains yttrium and aluminium
together to form so-called
the g is for garnet, which describes the structure
of the solid, and if you
excite this the neodymium atoms can emit light
in the infrared, like heat
rays you can’t see them. And then further
up here there is another
crystal which turns this infrared light into
green light so the green light
comes out at the end.
And also when neodymium is combined with iron
and boron it can form a
type of magnet which we call a ‘Permanent
Magnet’ and it is extremely
strong, one of the strongest that we actually
know of.
In order to get this doubling from the infrared
to the green to work, you
need to have pulses of light. So green lasers,
although to the eye, look
as if they are continuous are actually very
rapid pulses which are very
intense which is why these pointers are quite
dangerous if you point
them in the wrong direction in a lecture.
Because I wave my hands so
much, I never use these in lectures. But I
know that you the cameraman
have also used…
Hello.
…used neodymium, because neodymium is element
number 60 and the
cameraman’s future mother-in-law was 60
a few days ago and so we
provided a sample of neodymium, element 60,
for him to present to her
as a birthday present.
Happy Birthday Marion!